تتحدثين عن انتهاء البحث في مناطق
وامكانيه استمرار البحث في مناطق اخرى
يعني عندما نتحدث عن لا يزال هناك عشرات
المباني في منطقه مثل جنديرس لم يتمكن
الطرق الانقاص من العمل فيها يعني ان
الامل انتهى بالنسبه لهؤلاء الذين هم تحت
هذه الارقاد والذين هم بالمئات وليسوا
بالعشرات حقيقه الامر لان من بعض المباني
التي تمكنت فرق الانقاذ من اخراج الجسميين
منها او اخراج احياء توفوا لاحقا او توفى
بعضهم لاحقا لنتحدث عن مئات من الاشخاص قد
يصل عددهم الى نحو الف ما بالك على الذين
لا يسالون تحت الارقام ذا الجهود مستمره
جهود كانت جباره ولكن مع الاسف التخاذل
الدولي كان هو النقطه الاساس واليوم اليوم
الخامس والامل يعني ضئيل جدا في العثور
على احياء اليات لم تدخل فرق
مساعدات رغم الاعلان عن فتح الحدود معابر
على الحدود التركيه السوريه تفتح ولكن لا
شيء يصل بهذا ما تقول
هو بحاجه للوصول الى هذه المناطق معناته
الحكومه المؤقته للرئاسه عبد الرحمن مصطفى
من مناطق الاداره الذاتيه المعابر مع
النظام مغلقه الولايات المتحده الامريكيه
بدايه قالت بان العقوبات قيصر القانون
قيصر لا يؤثر على دعم بالنسبه لضحايا
زلزال لاحقان لانه يؤثر حقيقه الامر وان
الشحنه لانه الولايات المتحده ما زالت
تقول وحتى الاتحاد الاوروبي يقول بانه كل
العقوبات المفروضه على سوريا لا تشمل
المساعدات الانسانيه
اذا لم
للمساعدات لماذا يعني لا يصل تصل الوقود
يعني نتحدث عن سيدتي في مناطق النظام
مناطق المعارضه هناك بحاجه
العاملين في الاغاثه العمليين في الانقاذ
بحاجه الى وقود لاستمرار عمل الالياتهم
اذا كان الوقود لا يوجد في لدى الكثير من
الجهات فانها سيؤثر على كل شيء واثلا وحتى
السوريين الذين هم خالص اذا ما ارادوا
كانوا بالبدايه جمع تبرعات ماليه وارسالها
بشكل عاجل كان سيؤثر على هؤلاء يعني
الموجودين في الخارج ولكن العقوبات
الامريكيه تؤثر حقيقه الامر واثرت وكان
هناك بعض الدول العربيه تريد ارسال
مساعدات اكثر ولكن كانت تخش العقوبات
الامريكيه لكن دعينا نعود الى ارض الواقع
ارض الواقع بان هناك الان يعني م الاف
المشردين وليس عشرات الالاف حقيقه الامر
يعيشون في خيام يعيشون في ملاعب هناك يعني
محاولات اهليه لمساعده هؤلاء ولكن دعينا
نقول الذي خرج من منزله هربا من انهيار
المبنى خرج من ملابسه هذا الرجل وهذا
الطفل وهذه الامراه منذ ايام هي في هذه
الخيمه بنفس الملابس نفس بدون تدفئه في
كثير من القيم لا يوجد فيها تدفئه
والاجواء يعني مخيفه في تلك المناطق